[Music]
echidnas aren't aggressive but they do
have an excellent form of Defense which
is all of their cool spikes but when you
are a walking ball of needles how do you
actually get your groove on if you know
what I'm saying sounds like it could be
a bit dangerous
[Music]
well here we've got an Australian
Echidna the only one of two mammals in
the world will lay eggs
God it's so cute anymore
they are a special mammal they're a
monotreme and they
do produce an egg the other one what
lays eggs is the Platypus
they're having a good feed so they've
used their claws to rip holes and then
they're long and sticky skinny tongue
goes in and out really really quickly
and that's how they actually draw all of
the ants and termites back into their
mouth
and he's big is extremely sensitive it
has Electro receptors in it so as it is
going along it is sensing the
electropulses of the muscles inside the
invertebrates that it's searching for
just check well let me look at these
birds one of the ways
is that the little spur
oh it's much smaller than I thought
so echidnas are monomorphic that means
that from the outside it's really hard
to tell whether they're male or female
because they don't have any external
genitalia Right male echidnas do have a
Spur at the back and it's sort of like
the Platypus spur except echidnas aren't
venomous they're much more likely to
kill you with cuteness
oh God oh God
oh God
dang it
oh [__] off for crying out loud
so echidnas have four heads on their
penis
and they can shoot sperm out of two
heads at once one side or the other
inside the female Echidna in her
reproductive system there's actually
like sort of like a y shape there's two
pockets so maybe it's sort of like this
Evolution that's happened over time
where they go poo and go off to the left
and then in the next time they go and go
off to the right the whole thing is
super weird but that's what you would
expect from an egg laying mammal
so Echidna mating trains I have never
seen one in real life but I've seen lots
of videos like this which basically show
a female being trailed by a big group of
males there's even reports of there
being up to 11 male suitors following
one female this is a mature female and
she's wafting sexy scents all over the
landscape as she's going along can't
help it she just smells sexy and as she
goes all of the male echidnas are
putting their little beaks up and going
I want a bit of that but because
echidnas are essentially extremely
polite animals they just form a line and
follow her around until eventually she's
ready to mate
oh
this would totally be the part where
your nana would lean over and put her
hand over your eyes
after the train goes on for a very long
time and the female is ready to mate She
lays down nice and flat on the ground
and then it's sort of like a bit of a
fight for who dares wins you know it
might be the strongest male the quickest
male the last male standing gets to go
in and what he actually does is digs
down beside her and forms a little
Hollow and then he moves his rear end in
underneath and they mate like this so
he's sort of around the side of her and
that's how he avoids getting spiked
I feel like I need to invert my eyes I
mean who filmed this and then what's
that third Echidna doing is he just like
just watching
echidnas are one of Australia's cutest
and most for love creatures but they are
weird and it's safe to say that they're
sex slaves do not buck that trend
[Music]
if you like this video and you want to
find out more amazing animal facts then
you should find my podcast It's weekly
and it's called what the duck yes you
can find it on the ABC listen app and
also anywhere that you find your
podcasts